[Music]
it's Grammy weekend so we want to take a
quick moment to recognize all the
nominees who've appeared on CBS this
morning Saturday over the past year we
brought you the songs and stories of 16
different artists who are up for awards
tomorrow night in all they are nominated
for 20 Grammys and we'll continue that
with another nominee this morning
Saturday session Robert Randolph and the
family band has been thrilling live
audiences since since 2001 he has since
been named one of the 100 best
guitarists of all time by Rolling Stone
the band's latest effort got soul is
nominated for Best contemporary blues
album will hear them perform in a moment
but first Michelle Miller sat down with
Randolph at the Gibson guitar showroom
here in New York would you say you're
more blues than gospel John Mayer Court
coined the phrase of me as rocks bull
he's locked bull rocks boys like Magog
are all in gospel he's like he's like
rocks bull so that's what I would say it
is because it's a bit you know it's a
bit of it all rocks bull didn't come
naturally growing up singing and
performing in church
Randolph began playing the pedal steel
guitar as a teenager and while church
music was a heavy favorite in his
household he wasn't allowed to listen to
much else no we didn't listen to no
blues no rock n roll we would get in
trouble we were listening he attacked we
had to sneak and listen to all of the
Biggie and Tupac and all the rap music
and R&B because in our church you know
you when you're the musician you know we
we had our own sort of music scene now
attracting more mainstream audiences
Randolph keeps his crew all in the
family his family band so to speak is
made up of his cousin's sister and two
outside members always has been
but he's not against mixing it up with
other musicians like legends Eric
Clapton and Santana they're fans of his
and are all on board the Randolph train
for his latest and fifth studio album it
was really trying to get people to to
dance and feel good but listen to the
message of love and we all need to just
stick together and get together sorry
folks I'm in the uplifting business not
in a lover business you might want to
make a love after you've been up which
is fine you know which is great why is
it so important to you to uplift what
for me is really important to uplift
through my music and songs because
that's just who I am that's just where
we come from music that I make that we
make as a band is able to turn people
around it is the greatest joy in the
whole world